from the company you can milk a cash cow
almost as well as Disney comes the
internet sensation that has people all
over the world staring at their computer
screen say jeez you can get paid for
this nostalgia critic behold a comedian
with the squeegee high-pitched voice
like Sam Kinison only you wish this one
died instead of him getting recognition
for doing what no other person online
has ever done like scream loudly get
facts wrong force painful means chronic
time and act like his opinion is the
only one that matters seriously do you
guys even read YouTube comments watch
this entitled nitpicking cry-baby give
birth to a million other entitled
nitpicking cry babies each one more
desperate to ride his coattails to
internet fame and glory kinda like what
he did originally ah question how this
whiny little tool actually got so much
attention that Hollywood constantly
tries to take him down for critiquing
their worst piece-of-shit material yeah
taking down review of Cat in the Hat
isn't gonna change anyone's opinion on
it guys and do her a man with so little
talent that you'll be asking yourself
how he keeps getting celebrities you
didn't know you wanted to meet boy shit
is that Rufio
he looks amazing oh look it's pinging
the brain swearing at each other how the
hell did he get this well come on sit
back and enjoy an overly unqualified
twit rip apart terrible movies and shows
even though he's made terrible movies
and shows witness and clarify when an
obviously bad film is obviously bad the
they the ongoing question raised with
every episode what really counts as
nostalgic
I mean Jurassic world really and still
in theaters dude and see a man do what
you know you should be getting paid to
do but he just got to it a little bit
faster than you did
nanny nanny nanny starring the black guy
the shore chick who Rachel babes
blasphemy that guy who's probably
funnier than everybody in the Eve's
way too many favors and
privilege the job if you're gonna
download this you better make it quick
cuz you never know and fuck you guys